why is it ending uh i don't know ask
dave and dan when they come through
um we could have gone to 11 12
13 seasons but uh they i guess they
wanted a life
you wanted it to keep going well it you
know if you've read
my novels you know there was enough
material for
for more seasons
the realm do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agree to tell each other over
and over till we forget that it's a
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones video
in this video i will be discussing
something i have wanted to know for many
many years
once again thanks to james hibbert's
book fire cannot kill a dragon
we finally know what scene from game of
thrones george rr martin hates the most
according to george rr martin his least
favorite scene actually happens in the
very first season of the show
now i don't want to say he was lying
about this although i can't help but
wonder if he was honest about what scene
he actually hates the most
let me explain what i mean by that i
don't know about all of you
but i have always wondered what george
rr martin actually thought about the
show
especially when it comes to how it ended
ever since game of thrones started to
distance itself from the books right
around season 4 in season 5.
it seemed as if george rr martin had a
falling out with the show's writers
db weiss and david benioff you see
george was once a writer on the show as
well
some of the best episodes in game of
thrones were written by george rr martin
like the battle of blackwater bay and
the lion in the rose
but right after season 4 he stopped
writing for the show
not only did he stop writing for game of
thrones he also stopped watching it
and talking about it on social media in
fact whenever a new season of the show
would come out
george would actually go to his social
media to talk about how great other
shows were instead of game of thrones
now if you would ask george he will say
he stopped writing on the show because
he wanted to focus on finishing the wins
of winner
but i don't think that's entirely
accurate after he stopped writing
episodes in season 4
george went on to help create other
shows and write other books
so if he was too busy writing the wins
of winner to write for game of thrones
then how did he have all this time to do
these other things as well as attending
many different conventions over the
years
this is only speculation but i think his
relationship
with dan and dave started to
disintegrate as they went further and
further away from his books
when you think about it this was right
around the same time he stopped writing
for the show
season 5 was the first season he did not
write an episode
and that was when the show really
started to separate itself from the
books
i think he did not want to associate
himself with that version of the story
but like i said
this is only a guess obviously i don't
know what really happened behind the
scenes
regardless of what happened i still love
the show for many years after that
and i still love the books either way i
have still wondered how george felt
about the show
after he left he is still creating shows
for hbo
like house of the dragon so i'm afraid
we won't find out anytime
soon as long as george is under contract
by hbo
i don't think he will reveal how he
really feels but george has now gone on
record and said what his
least favorite scene is let me show you
what he said then i will give you my
thoughts because i do think there is a
reason why he chose this scene
instead of so many others that had a
greater impact on the story
the article from entertainment weekly
says george rr martin has a least
favorite scene in game of thrones
and it's probably not the one you'd
expect in my new book fire cannot kill a
dragon
the song of ice and fire saga author
candidly discusses many aspects of hbo's
hit series
he has high praise for many elements of
the epic adaptation
such as the show's staging annette
stark's death and the red
wedding but occasionally he's critical
as well
martin reveals his least favorite scene
came in the show's first season
when the production struggled with a
budget that was very large for 2011
roughly 6 million each episode but still
not large enough to stage many elements
of his grand fantasy vision
george said where we really fell down in
terms of budget was my least favorite
scene in the entire show
in all eight seasons king robert goes
hunting martin says
four guys walking around on foot through
the woods carrying spears
and robert is giving renly a hard time
in the books
robert goes off hunting we get word he
was gored by a boar
and they bring him back and he dies so i
never did a hunting scene
but i knew what a royal hunting party
was like there would have been a hundred
guys
there would have been pavilions there
would have been huntsmen
there would have been dogs there would
have been horns blowing
that's how a king goes hunting he
wouldn't have just been walking through
the woods with three of his friends
holding spears hoping to meet a boar
but by then we could not afford horses
or dogs or the other things he mentioned
this is the scene he hated the most i'm
sorry but i find that a little hard to
believe
considering how insignificant that scene
actually is
now keep in mind i know nothing but i
may have an idea of why he said it was
this scene
instead of something from the later
seasons that greatly affected the show's
outcome for example
let's say george does hate the way jaime
lannister's story ended
or the way danny's story ended or
whoever he can't say it was his least
favorite because
then we would know his way will be
different therefore it would spoil his
books even more than they've already
been spoiled
if he said the way euron greyjoy dies or
the way cersei lannister dies was really
stupid
then we would know his version of their
final scene will be very different
i think this is why he chose a scene
from the first season that involves a
character that's already dead in his
books
that way we don't find out any other
details about how his story does end
again this is only a guess but this is
how i can justify his answer
although he may really feel that way for
all i know
he may really think that scene is worse
than all the other scenes that affected
how the story actually ends
maybe it's just me but if i were to
choose my least favorite scene
the one george rr martin chose would not
even make my top 100 worst scenes in the
series
but at the end of the day he knows way
more than i do who am i to say what
scene is the worst
let me know your thoughts down below do
you agree with george or do you think
there is another scene that's worse than
the one he chose
i would love to hear what you have to
say now before i go i do want to give a
special shout out to everyone who is
kind enough to donate to my friends
gofundme
first of all i will never be able to
thank you enough not only for your
donations but also for the condolences
for you to take a few moments out of
your day to say the things that you did
really meant a lot to me and his family
the least i can do is thank each and
every one of you who left me a message
saying you were able to help out a great
friend of mine
i want to thank billy big balls keith
struchen
josh tom neville not your little
princess
joe jay for love only jacqueline a
martin horowitz movies are terrible eric
thomas
nabil ramathullah charmaine roberts
ursachan lusty argonian maid
draz o'brien chief silverback thomas
lewis
teutonic knight matthew scott caesar
bandersnatch
calisia mde mj tiffany lewis
david cleave laura smith sandy hartcorn
ann alford rusco jamie bachmann
rewind that stephanie spain quinnida
tokun orimo eight mitch
longfinger kirsten rose kiersten riley
med lampard matthew fusco cookie love
daisy 1339 samuel bailey og
wacko david mcgeegan kt lindsay
oppel rue freda felcher 1 eric turner
minxish kelly mcclure tam hutchins
michael barker terry mcclure glitched
sound
jess voss melinda redmon reefer madness
beau w the mr saxy ryan maxey
sincerely sicilian british redneck
malcolm palmer louis alberto vargas
dylan stacy allen thompson s akantorin
ashwara morugan chris jermaine
backfish lp mp collector anna sabay
feifsan horzbane kara stone leo ward
shapiro crash and mysterio bro
james gillen lazzaro fernandez courtney
vaughn
matthew hawkins ali o'daniel angela
washington
and corey melendez once again i just
want to thank all of you for your
donations and or your kind words
thanks to all of you his family will be
able to get him the service he needs
i hope all of you have a great day i
will see you again very soon
bye
[Music]
you